well everybody has there
own choice
about what they believe in you know the freedom
to pursue different things and diversity of answers
people come up with
thats a great thing there is no single model
that you know should create this ranking of you know
you get this single score
you've got people who do
science an contribute
you've got people who do social services
people who do teaching
people who do entreunpreneur things
and
you know the great thing about our socity is
if you're lucky enough to get a good education
then you can find
that fulfillment  in a variety of ways
so i dont have a metric
that would apply uh
and you know universally and and comeout with a score
I feel awful that many people dont
get the educational opportunity
that lets them pick
uh and so they can decide
and and pursue
what there definition of fulfillment is